I just rejoined my original tribe first
thing we did was a challenge boom won
that and then to come out here and see
what they've all got accomplished looks
like they work together that's a good
thing two-time Survivor contestant Keith
nail has died he was 62 years old
Keith's son West tells E.T he died
Tuesday afternoon after his battle with
cancer he says they found out about it
in January Keith's brother Kevin nail
describes Keith's death as a life taken
way too soon it happened so quickly
cancer ate him up he passed his
afternoon at his home in Shreveport
Louisiana I wasn't a real super fan but
everybody saying it you know I watched
Survivor just like everybody I mean but
I've missed episodes through the years
and then it showed on the it showed in
my skills on the game Keith participated
in two seasons of Survivor first on
Survivor San Juan Del Sur with Wes in
2014. it's show time for me I feel time
for you I got a social aspect physical
aspect middle aspect I feel like I got
it all you're about as mentally strong
as that rock I'm from Louisiana and you
just don't sit around Louisiana saying
hey let's fly down to Nicaragua you say
let's fly over to Hawaii let's fly down
to Cancun let's Nicaragua never comes in
the
it's something you'll never have the
opportunity especially with your son the
Louisiana native made it pretty far that
season ending up in the final four
I would go back again I was just telling
somebody oh I don't know if I'd go back
I'd like to go back with Wesley I don't
know if they'd do another one of them
again going back by myself might have to
think about that well thanks to the
Public's vote Keith got a second chance
the following year but this time solo
for Survivor Cambodia I never thought
I'd make the cut but here I am happy to
be here now fourth place is a hard pill
to swallow so I'm not gonna change a lot
but maybe tweak a little bit once again
Keith did well in the competition he was
eliminated just two days before the
final Tribal Council you know you try to
play with a little integrity that's why
I didn't play that cheesy Idol there you
know but anyway crazy ride out here I
want to thank all of America for giving
me this great adventure I tried to bring
it home for the old guys it just a
couple of days shy his two
Survivor co-star Kelly Wentworth shared
a tribute to her late friend writing
Keith a man with the purest heart who
brought humor into moments where it was
needed most she adds this is a
devastating loss this up ranks up there
pretty close to the top I mean if not
the top I think I'll stick with Survivor
foreign